in this day and age of rapid-fire
frame-by-frame analysis there's not much
that goes unnoticed in modern movies
secretly I'm just like hey man where is
the chase and how do I cut to it but
there have been some cinematic Easter
eggs that were so subtle they slipped
right by us until years later when
eagle-eyed fans finally spotted
something new in film favorites here are
a few movie Easter eggs that went
unnoticed for a surprisingly long time
go Red Wings
it took decades for one not so minor
detail from John Hughes's 1986
existential comedy Ferris Bueller's Day
Off to finally be explained in the movie
teen slacker Ferris takes his girlfriend
Sloane his best friend Cameron on a
senior skip day adventure through
Chicago together the trio hits some of
the Windy City's most iconic sites
including Wrigley Field and The Art
Institute of Chicago all the while
Cameron wore a Detroit Red Wings hockey
jersey which is nothing short of
blasphemy since the team is an old rival
of the Chicago Blackhawks it wasn't
until the film's 30th anniversary
celebration in 2016 that the reason for
cams peculiar thread selection was
finally revealed actor Alan ruck
explained that his iconic shirt was
actually a nod to the friction he had
with his dad in the movie ruck said that
the director quote decided Cameron had a
horrible relationship with his father
but a great relationship with his
grandfather who lived in Detroit and
could take Cameron to Red Wings games
that's all it was and it was never
explained the movie
holy Groot in late 2015
guardians of the galaxy director James
Gunn revealed cut image from the movie
on his Facebook page in which his
animated tree hero Groot resided over a
table full of characters arranged just
like Leonardo da Vinci's the Last Supper
after one fan joked that group could be
his own cross because he's a tree and
thusly made of wood Gunn mentioned that
the fan wasn't far off and there was a
similarly Christ themed Easter egg that
fans had not yet noticed then someone
found it as the team ship is about to
crash Groot stretches his arms out in a
shape resembling Christ on the cross
shielding the other guardians which is a
pretty christ-like gesture as well
think about it medication memo Hannibal
Lector is definitely had his share
memorable moments over the years
arguably the most memorable of all came
in Silence of the Lambs when he told
Clarice Starling about another
government official who tried to match
wits with him a census taker once tried
to test me I ate his liver with some
fava beans and a nice Chianti it may not
have been obvious to everyone but that
maniacal menu description might have
contained a sinister clue see the movie
was based on Thomas Harris's 1988 novel
of the same name which was published at
a time when a certain antidepressant was
popularly prescribed that medication
known as an MAOI just so happened to
have advised against patients ingesting
items eerily similar to the ones he
described namely foods like liver fava
beans and red wine Hannibal himself
would have known this since he was a
psychiatrist so maybe he was giving
Clarice a hint that he'd gone off his
meds and planned his big escape from the
cell that separated him from the rest of
the world the potato strikes back the
Star Wars franchise might just be the
most-watched in history
needless to say over the years keen eyes
have spotted occasional gaffes mistakes
and an in-joke until the making of the
Empire Strikes Back
push the cast and crew to their limits
George Lucas wanting a break from
directing and daunted by the pressure of
following up Star Wars might not have
directed the sequel but he still took a
hands-on approach during the production
process especially when it came to the
special effects the film's famed
asteroid chase became a particular
sticking point for Lucas who reportedly
ordered the effects crew to redo it
several times bored frustrated and
inspired by a passing comment remarking
that the asteroids look like potatoes
the effects team decided to hide an
actual potato in an asteroid field
during a chase scene I think Ken Ralston
said ah hell looks like a potato just
put some potatoes and so they once in
the very distant very distance were
actual potatoes
Lucas himself apparently didn't notice
the prank until years later
audiences took their time - it wasn't
until the days of video and laserdisc
that viewers could freeze frame the
scene in place bought the spud thanks
for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel for
more videos like the one you just
watched
and let us know which little-known
Easter eggs you've noticed in movies